I love these things you missed episodes
They're really fun to make and they're a great way [for] me to explore the game with you guys
While I work on bigger projects in the background anyway like if you learn something new dislike if you don't Etc Etc
So there's this shard in the well
If you knock down the rock but everyone already knows that
Around the side though are these irritating pigs that chase you around the place if you aggro them
they're pretty evil and I kind of mean that in more than one way because
Did you know that they have around a [5%] chance of dropping a cracked red eye, orb?
[I] don't know if it's worth I growing them for that though
I'm sure we all have fond memories of being chased around [majula] by these little bastards so is it worth it
It's up to you while we're in this room
You'll notice this little book sticking out of the bookcase, and it was in Dark souls 1 as well in the Duke's archives
It's a little bit of an easter egg at this point
So it's a reference to a real book and you're gonna have to excuse me for butchering the French language
But I believe it's called
[Letizia] De Vivre by Paul Arca this name translates to the desire to live I guess it's kind of an ironic
statement considering
How undead lose the desire to live although whether it's ironic or not
I guess depends on the content of the book
I would love to know what it's about [French] varda video fans if you're out there [all] three of you. You know what to do
Moving on using a bonfire aesthetic in majula adds an extra Skeleton to the basement every time
Which at new game+ 10 can get pretty ridiculous?
Further within the basement are the fragments of the Lord vessel which can lead to all kinds of speculation?
Here's a picture [that] was floating around [awhile] ago showing the two pieces
It's clear that this is the same thing, but what is the significance of this feel free to debate in the comments?
I'll probably just end up talking about it in another video as
As we go deeper into the mansion we find something else interesting
Did you know that if you kill a boss then his corresponding area on the map will light up in flame?
but that's not all did you also know that if you use a bonfire aesthetic on A
Corresponding boss and kill him in [new] [game+] 10 then his flame will turn Blue?
I came across a thread on reddit where people were discussing this and people were kind of wondering
You know what will happen if we kill all the bosses in [new] [Game+] 10?
What happens if we turn all the flames blue? [I] think?
People are still holding out hope that there's something in this game that absolutely no one has discovered yet, and it's possible
we all hoped that the pendant would unlock some secret passageway in Dark Souls 1 and
Something along these lines is possible in Dark Souls 2 but it becomes more and more unlikely with every passing day
Another example of this is the emerald herald in the credits there is credit given to the voice actor of the herald as an adult
and the voice actor of [the] herald as a child
Yet the child herald isn't found within the game perhaps shall be included in some sort of future [Dlc]
We've been through the voice files of the game already, and I don't think we've found anything on this topic, but you can still hope
Moving along you might think that the armor merchant just sells a limited amount of armor
But did you know that he sells more gear depending on how many souls you've traded with him?
buy a thousand souls worth of armor and he'll sell the elite [knight] and the Royal soldier set by
[16000] souls worth of armor [with] him and he'll become really cocky transforming from a little timid man into an arrogant one and
So have we met oh sorry. It's just I've been awfully [busy] lately
He then sells the Alva set which is one of the better sets in the game
And there's also another secret here if you come to him with 0 souls while he's in
Arrogant prick mode then he'll take pity on you, [and] he gives you the transparent Aura set for free
From [shell] [qua]. We can get a bunch of really useful items you'll need the cat ring to traverse the pit in Majula easily
But did you also know [that] she gives you a pair of boots that help with falling damage after you kill the Rat King?
It's kind of annoying that she only gives them to you right [after] you really need them, but they're not bad
also, you get the covetous silver serpent ring after purchasing 10,000 souls worth items from Millennia and
Moving on to another NPC [one] of my favorites. This is lenna grassed the blacksmith in Majula
his face is identical to the one you find on the arch stone in Demon souls the one that depicts the
King of the Borough is underground
There's actually another reference to Demon souls in majula, or I think there is anyway you see this map in the mansion
It's in one of the demon [soul] cinematic, so I swear this landmass off to the side almost
perfectly Matches the map of Drangleic in Majula
But notice I call these things references not links to that game from a lore point of view
Dark souls is a completely different universe to Demon souls and this has been
Pointed out by the Devs multiple times that doesn't mean you can't think of it as related in your own head
You can keep your own head canon, but that's just what the devs have officially said, and that's pretty much it
let me know how many you got out of 10 leave a like if you learned something new
But from this point on this video is going to be a bit of an update video for those of you who are interested?
This is a chance to look at where we've been and where we kind of need to go from here
It's almost like traveling to [majula] after you beat a boss then warping out to the next zone you need to conquer
You know it's almost poetic, so let's start with the videos
I've [made] in the past my prepare to cry series comes to mind first there are [some] seriously
Heart-Wrenching stories in Dark Souls 2 and I bet you missed a bunch of them
So [I'm] really looking forward to bringing them to life
But the thing is as much as some of you might want me to I'm not going to rush them out of the door for
the Sake of Early Views I
made the original prepare to cry about a year into the life of dark souls and
While I'm not going to wait nearly as long as that to [release] prepare to cry
I'm also not going to release them until I'm ready if I do when it's going to be done, right?
You know another thing that's worth [mentioning]
Is that people don't actually have a good idea of what's [going] on in Dark Souls 2 right now
Prepare to cry is about interpretation of character stories
I take the most likely explanation
And I bring it to life in a logical way
If people don't understand what's going on in Dark Souls 2 then they won't understand my interpretation
and if they don't understand my interpretation
then I'm going to have to spend a lot of time explaining it and
If I have to actually explain something too much in prepare to cry then it's going to be really bad storytelling
So it makes sense for me to cover speculation first
So that's what I'm going to do prepare to why maybe still thinking about series names speaking of which they last few days
I've been working on a video summing up with the main plot points in Dark Souls 2 and this is a
Gargantuan task and the Script for that video is already about
[4000] Words long it took a long time to tie everything together and to do all the research
So when you don't hear from me for a while. [just] assume
I'm working on something bigger because not every video can be made in a day [or] two and
Speaking of bigger projects. I'm in something of a transition period With this channel right [now] with all the pledges on Patreon
[I] now have the ability because of you guys to invest in really big projects
and it has to be bigger than I originally anticipated you know because I didn't know how much I was going to make and
One of my main [goals] with patreon is to be able to afford more soul songs so first off
That's what I've been doing. [I've] been
[painstakingly] trying to find singers songwriters performers who can bring the souls universe to life and
When you think about it there aren't that many people who fit that criteria?
You know I have to search for all this talent myself and it's hard to find the perfect person
You know it's hard to find someone who can produce the tone
Somebody who's happy with the rate I give them somebody who?
Has the free time and someone willing to learn about the souls universe and then once I find that person
There's a lot of emailing back and forth as we hash out those details so as you can imagine
This [is] taken up a lot [of] my time, but I've had a lot [of] success
I have found two people so far and they're so good
I can't wait to share it with you, so I think part of that is because when I tell them about this community
It's really hard not to be inspired because of you guys
So I've been busy compiling assets these past few days things that tell them about the universe documents pictures
assets videos things that can guide them when they create a soul song for us
So again just to reiterate when you don't see a video pop up for a few days
Assume that I'm working on some projects that will show up later
So how many of you are looking forward to the PC version? I'm sookie
I can't wait one of the best things about dark souls PC was that video creators could use cheat engine?
To manipulate the camera get really cool Angles and also most importantly
Walk to any bonfire from the very start [of] the game this saved so much time and allowed for much better videos
That's another reason. I'm not going to bother making many prepare to cry videos until PC
Those videos deserve better resolution and more polish that I can give them and the PC version
Will allow me to give them that level of polish in terms of content on the channel right now?
I want the next few weeks, and maybe months to be about exploring the game with you guys
That's the theme and story mode is part of that
It's about exploring the story one step at a time and the things you miss series is just about that as well
It's about combing every area for interesting tidbits and putting those in a focused video
That's fun to watch story mode and things you missed will probably be expanded to include more areas in future
[I] realized that my things, but week's episode didn't really have enough good facts and so from now on
I think I'll only cover areas where there are seriously some hidden things as usual this short video has no irritating ads
Thanks to the folks over patreon calm
[and] I'll catch you guys [next] time